One of my favourite little moments in my working week is when I'm preparing to meet a new client and I click the smart import button in write-up. Before I moved over to write-up, I used to spend so much time manually inputting details, checking spellings, chasing information and worrying whether I'd copied things across correctly. Now clients complete their intake forms remotely in their own time on their own device and with one click of that magic little smart import button, their information securely populates into the system ready. for me. That means names, addresses, GP details, next-of-kin information and more are already
我工作周中最喜欢的小瞬间之一，就是准备见新客户时，点击 Write-Up 中的智能导入按钮。在转用 Write-Up 之前，我曾花费大量时间手动输入详细信息、检查拼写、追问信息，并担心是否复制正确。现在，客户可以在自己的时间、使用自己的设备远程完成入职表格，只需轻轻点击那个神奇的智能导入按钮，他们的信息就会安全地填充到系统中，准备就绪。这意味着姓名、地址、全科医生详细信息、近亲信息等，在我们见面之前就已经
there before we even meet. It feels smoother and more professional for clients, but honestly, it also really reduces mental load for me as a clinician and business owner too. And when you work in healthcare, having systems you can trust matters. Right-Up is the practice management platform built in the UK for UK practitioners. Have a look at write-up.com. That's W-R-I-T-E. P-U-P-P-com. Use code Marianne 30 for 30 days free and 30% off your first six months and then you can see whether it's that smart import button or another of write-ups great features that makes you smile too. Imagine walking around carrying bags of dog poo all day. Not your dog, not your poo, yet somehow you're still left carrying it.
在那里了。这对客户来说感觉更顺畅、更专业，但老实说，这也确实减轻了我作为临床医生和企业主的心理负担。当你从事医疗保健工作时，拥有值得信赖的系统非常重要。Right-Up 是专为英国从业者在英国打造的诊所管理平台。请访问 write-up.com。即 W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P.com。使用代码 Marianne 30 可获得 30 天免费试用，并享受前六个月 30% 的折扣，然后你就可以看看是那个智能导入按钮还是 Write-Up 的其他强大功能让你也感到开心。想象一下整天提着几袋狗屎到处走。不是你的狗，也不是你的屎，但不知何故，你还是得提着它。
And for many people, that's what happens in relationships. They carry other people's emotions, other people's expectations, other people's problems, until they become exhausted, overwhelmed and quietly resentful. Today, Forensic Psychologist Dr Nicole Harvey and I are exploring the psychology of people-pleasing. We're getting to groups with why putting down other people's emotional baggage can feel so difficult, but when you do begin to do that, how it might just change your life. Hi, welcome along to psychology actually. I'm Dr. Marianne Trette, a qualified clinical psychologist and I'm joined here today by Dr Nicole
对许多人来说，这就是人际关系中发生的事情。他们背负着别人的情绪、别人的期望、别人的问题，直到变得精疲力竭、不知所措并暗自怨恨。今天，法医心理学家妮可·哈维博士和我将探讨讨好型人格的心理学。我们将深入探讨为什么放下别人的情感包袱会感觉如此困难，但当你开始这样做时，它可能会如何改变你的生活。嗨，欢迎来到《心理学实际上》。我是临床心理学家玛丽安·特雷特博士，今天和我一起的是妮可·哈维博士
Harvey who's a forensic psychologist. Hi Nicole. Hello, thanks for having me. So we got chatting in the DMs so to speak because I was really interested in this idea of holding on to other people's emotional or physical. stuff that maybe we just shouldn't or shouldn't in the way that we are. How did that come about as a realisation for you? So I have been in private practice for since 2021, so about five years now. And I just see a lot of clients who hold on to other people's emotions or who feel like they ought to be responsible for other people's emotions.
她是一位法医心理学家。你好，妮可。你好，谢谢你邀请我。所以我们是在私信中聊起来的，因为我对这种“背负着别人的情感或物质负担”的想法非常感兴趣，也许我们根本不应该背负，或者不应该以我们现在的方式背负。你是如何意识到这一点的？我从 2021 年开始从事私人执业，到现在大约五年了。我看到很多客户背负着别人的情绪，或者觉得他们应该对别人的情绪负责。
emotions. And so I wanted to create a resource that would help people to understand a bit better what was happening in their sort of relationship dynamics. And well, obviously the dog poo bag analogy is not a resource it really in itself, but it's an image and it's quite a clear one. And it's one that my clients find very helpful. So that's where it started and then became something a bit bigger more recently where I discovered that actually a I could develop a test around this and help people to understand what was happening for them, not just my clients, but anyone who wanted to sort of, or maybe identified as a people pleaser. Yeah.
情绪。所以我想创建一个资源，帮助人们更好地理解他们的人际关系动态中发生了什么。嗯，显然狗屎袋的比喻本身并不是一个资源，但它是一个形象，而且非常清晰。我的客户觉得它很有帮助。所以这就是它的起源，最近它变得更大了一些，我发现实际上我可以围绕这个开发一个测试，帮助人们理解他们身上发生了什么，不仅是我的客户，还有任何想要了解，或者可能认为自己是讨好型人格的人。是的。
Yeah, so the idea is that you suddenly realise that you're carrying bags of dog poo obviously are not yours and whether we can put that down or give that back? Yeah, pretty much. That's exactly it. So, yeah, sometimes we are carrying things that don't belong to us. And because of things that have happened maybe in our past, we feel very responsible for fixing things or absorbing emotions that really don't belong to us. But what we end up with is just a whole load of dog poo bags that don't belong to us
是的，所以这个想法是，你突然意识到你提着的狗屎袋显然不是你的，我们是否可以放下它或把它还回去？是的，差不多就是这样。所以，是的，有时我们背负着不属于我们的东西。由于我们过去可能发生的事情，我们觉得非常有责任去解决问题或吸收那些根本不属于我们的情绪。但我们最终得到的是一大堆不属于我们的狗屎袋
that we could put down. And some people just really struggle to know how to put them down. So that's what I wanted to help people with. Okay. So this is a really powerful image. is that we might also have almost pockets of dog poo bags that we maybe are not even aware that we're carrying. I had this one image of just carrying the one fresh dog poo bag, but actually it could be that we are carrying lots of other people's stuff.
我们可以放下它们。有些人真的很难知道如何放下它们。所以这就是我想帮助人们的地方。好的。这是一个非常有力的形象。我们可能还有几乎是口袋里的狗屎袋，我们甚至可能没有意识到我们在背着它们。我脑海中有一个只提着一个新鲜狗屎袋的形象，但实际上我们可能背着很多别人的东西。
Yeah, and it can build up. And the problem with it building up is that actually what happens in real time is that you start to become resentful because what you're seeing is other people getting all of their emotional needs met or even their physical needs. And meanwhile, you're there with, like, lumbered with all of this dog poop, you know, that you didn't ask for, and you're not getting any of your needs met. And so that builds resentment. It builds anger. And I see that clients sometimes struggled to connect with that because they are so deep in this kind of people-pleasing mode. But it is there. It is usually there. And once they do connect to it, they realize how much they have been carrying. Okay. So if we've got someone listening or watching, what kind of early indicators or how could they tune in to knowing whether this is something that they've got going on for them or not?
是的，它会堆积起来。它堆积起来的问题在于，实际上实时发生的情况是，你开始变得怨恨，因为你看到的是别人满足了他们所有的情感需求，甚至是身体需求。而与此同时，你却被这些你没要求的狗屎所累，而且你没有任何需求得到满足。所以这会产生怨恨。它会产生愤怒。我看到客户有时很难与这种感觉建立联系，因为他们太深陷于这种讨好型人格模式中了。但它确实存在。它通常就在那里。一旦他们与它建立联系，他们就会意识到他们背负了多少东西。好的。所以如果我们有听众或观众，他们有什么样的早期指标，或者他们如何才能察觉到这是否是他们正在经历的事情？
So they could take my test. They could take the test on the website, which would give them a good indication. but really it's about, I guess, tapping into how they feel when they interact with people. So if they feel like other people try to make them feel guilty for things or they end up feeling guilty for things that they're not really sure belongs to them. So as an example, your partner asks you to do something. You don't have capacity to do it. And you say, sorry, I can't do that right now. you know, let me know if you need anything else. And they go off in a half.
所以他们可以参加我的测试。他们可以在网站上参加测试，这会给他们一个很好的指示。但实际上，我认为这关乎于在与人互动时感受自己的感觉。所以如果他们觉得别人试图让他们为某些事情感到内疚，或者他们最终为一些他们不确定是否属于自己的事情感到内疚。举个例子，你的伴侣让你做某事。你没有能力去做。你说，抱歉，我现在做不到。你知道，如果你还需要什么，请告诉我。然后他们就生气地走开了。
If you are someone who is then left feeling guilty for saying no, and just because you didn't have the capacity to do whatever they wanted you to do in that moment, and you feel the need to fix something, that's a pretty good indication that you might be in that zone of people pleasing. That's a very small example, but probably in everyday kind of a one. Yeah, absolutely. So it's using appropriate boundaries that are realistic for us, but then feeling bad about putting those boundaries in place and asserting yourself. Yes, it's that, but then it's also people who say yes when they mean no.
如果你是一个在拒绝后感到内疚的人，仅仅因为你当时没有能力做他们想让你做的事，并且你觉得有必要去解决某些问题，这是一个很好的迹象，表明你可能处于讨好型人格的区域。这是一个非常小的例子，但可能是一个日常的例子。是的，绝对是。所以这是使用对我们来说现实的适当界限，但随后因为设置这些界限并坚持自己而感到难过。是的，就是这样，但这也包括那些口是心非的人。
So in that scenario, someone might say, yeah, sure, I can do it when they actually don't have the capacity to do it. And what then happens is that they start to feel resentful. They might not feel it in the moment, but it will be there. It will be building up. They start to feel resentful. They might start to feel angry towards the other person. And sometimes that anger gets pushed down for so long that it ends up coming out in completely the wrong place, right?
所以在那种情况下，有人可能会说，好的，没问题，我能做，而实际上他们根本没有能力去做。然后发生的事情是，他们开始感到怨恨。他们可能当时感觉不到，但它会存在。它会不断积累。他们开始感到怨恨。他们可能会开始对另一个人感到愤怒。有时这种愤怒被压抑了太久，以至于最终在完全错误的地方爆发出来，对吧？
So at a server, you know, at a restaurant, for example. But it will be there and it will be building. And rather than actually saying how you feel, so saying actually, no, I can't do that right now. I'm really sorry and leaving it at that and recognising that any emotion that comes from the other person is theirs to deal with, they would take that on as a personal responsibility to resolve. Yeah. And I'm guessing this doesn't just crop up in intimate relationships. You know, this can very easily crop up in workplaces as well, can't it? Especially if managers are just used to going, oh, I need this doing, do this, but then don't necessarily help you to reprioritise what you've
比如在餐馆的服务员身上。但它会存在，并且会不断积累。而不是真正说出你的感受，比如，实际上，不，我现在做不到。我真的很抱歉，然后就此打住，并认识到来自对方的任何情绪都是他们自己需要处理的，他们会将其视为个人责任去解决。是的。我猜这不仅仅出现在亲密关系中。你知道，这也很容易出现在工作场所，不是吗？特别是如果经理习惯于说，哦，我需要做这个，做那个，但并不一定帮你重新安排你
already got on your plays. Yeah, it's kind of potential for all of our relationships. Absolutely. And I think probably worse where there's authority in a relationship, because if your manager comes along and says, oh, can you do this for me? The impulse is to say, yeah, of course, because you want to show willing. You want to, yeah, you want to be seen as someone who does good work. And presumably you want to eventually get a promotion or whatever.
已经手头上的工作。是的，这在我们的所有关系中都有可能发生。绝对是。而且我认为在有权威的关系中可能更糟，因为如果你的经理走过来问，哦，你能帮我做这个吗？冲动就是说，好的，当然，因为你想表现出意愿。你想，是的，你想被视为一个工作出色的人。而且大概你最终想获得晋升什么的。
So yeah, you'd be likely to say yes, but actually have you assessed whether you can actually manage that task? And I think a lot of people don't take that pause to think, can I actually do this? And if no, how am I going to manage that? And that can be really that part of managing it can be really difficult for some people, especially where they've gotten into this pattern of just saying yes and whether or not they mean it. Yeah, the power differential does muddy things, doesn't it? Especially in an organisational setting. But I think also in intimate relationships as well,
所以是的，你很可能会说好，但实际上你评估过你是否真的能完成那个任务吗？我认为很多人没有停下来思考，我真的能做到吗？如果不能，我该如何处理？对于某些人来说，处理这一部分可能真的非常困难，特别是当他们已经养成了无论是否真心都只会说好的模式时。是的，权力差异确实让事情变得模糊，不是吗？特别是在组织环境中。但我认为在亲密关系中也是如此，
especially if you've been burned by a partner before, then you might not think that you're allowed to say no or to assert yourself or to say, no, it's your turn to wash up. You know, jog on with that, please. Absolutely. And actually, for some people, there's, it's not just, just a sort of like a small worry about what happens if they say no, it's a really big fear. So if people have been in, you know, coercive controlling relationships or if they've grown
特别是如果你以前被伴侣伤害过，那么你可能认为自己不允许说不，或者坚持自己的立场，或者说，不，轮到你洗碗了。你知道，请走开。绝对是。实际上，对某些人来说，这不仅仅是对拒绝后会发生什么的小担忧，而是一种非常大的恐惧。如果人们曾经处于，你知道，强制控制的关系中，或者如果他们
up in a household where someone's one person's emotions really were big and sort of took precedence, they will feel fearful of what might happen if they say no or if they, yeah, if they don't take responsibility for the other person's emotions. So that is something that I see a lot where people actually, not only do they not know how to say no, they're actually really scared of saying no. And like I say, that leads to big problems with them, with their emotions. You know, where do they take their emotion?
在一个人情绪非常强烈且占据主导地位的家庭中长大，他们会害怕如果他们说不，或者如果他们，是的，如果他们不对对方的情绪负责，会发生什么。所以我经常看到这种情况，人们实际上不仅不知道如何说不，他们实际上真的很害怕说不。就像我说的，这会导致他们，以及他们的情绪出现大问题。你知道，他们把情绪带到哪里去了？
Where does the anger go? Where does the resentment go? It often goes internally. So it often gets channeled inwards, which is not ideal either. No. And actually, lot of the clients, work I do is with people who have had kind of complex trauma, kind of developmental trauma backgrounds and now they're adults. And it's interesting that actually the term anger feels
愤怒去哪了？怨恨去哪了？它通常是内部化的。所以它通常向内引导，这也不理想。不。实际上，我所做的工作中有很多客户是有复杂创伤、发展性创伤背景的人，现在他们是成年人了。有趣的是，实际上“愤怒”这个词感觉
like something that they often can't tap into or don't tap into. And so internalize that anger and it becomes kind of anxiety or self-harm. And when we begin to just explore even the concept of anger, what anger is, anger isn't always range. anger isn't always violence. Anger can just be saying a gentle asserting of your boundaries. And when we begin to practice that, it can really be transformational. Yeah, absolutely. I think part of this is also because I grew up being a pupil pleased on myself. So I've had a lot of therapy. It's still work in progress, but I have been a huge pupil pleaser myself.
就像他们经常无法触及或不去触及的东西。因此，他们将这种愤怒内化，变成了焦虑或自残。当我们开始探索愤怒的概念，什么是愤怒时，愤怒并不总是狂暴。愤怒并不总是暴力。愤怒可以只是温和地坚持你的界限。当我们开始练习这一点时，它真的可以产生变革性的影响。是的，绝对是。我认为这部分原因也是因为我自己曾经是一个讨好型人格者。所以我接受了很多治疗。这仍然是一个正在进行的过程，但我自己曾经是一个巨大的讨好型人格者。
and I noticed how I would lose myself in relationships. So it would become all about the other person. My whole life would become about the other person, which meant that I lost sight of who I was, what I wanted, what I needed. I couldn't ask for it. I couldn't, yeah. So it all just became really toxic in a way
我注意到我如何在人际关系中迷失自我。所以一切都变成了关于对方。我的整个生活都变成了关于对方，这意味着我失去了自我，失去了我想要什么，我需要什么。我无法要求它。我无法，是的。所以一切都变得非常糟糕，以至于
and meant that I felt like I had no power, really, not just in that relationship, but in general I just felt very small as a person. And that's not who I am. It's just who I had become. And thankfully, through therapy, through kind of understanding why I was like that and what was going on and how I could figure out what I wanted again and what I needed in a relationship felt so important and has really changed everything for me. Yeah, I'm sorry to hear that you had those experiences.
意味着我觉得我没有力量，真的，不仅是在那段关系中，而且总的来说，我作为一个人的感觉非常渺小。那不是我，那只是我变成了谁。值得庆幸的是，通过治疗，通过理解我为什么会那样，发生了什么，以及我如何能再次弄清楚我想要什么，以及我在一段关系中需要什么，这感觉非常重要，并真正改变了我的一切。是的，很遗憾听到你有过那些经历。
It isn't easy being a parent. I think, you know, I am a parent as well, but I've also been parented. And it's that idea of sometimes enmeshment where a parent hasn't been able to really see that their child has their own wants, needs and desires. And, you know, I would consider my job well done is if when my boys are older, they don't need to have me in their life, but they choose to have me in their life and that I can tolerate them making different choices. I can tolerate them making, even now I can tolerate them making unwise choices. Obviously, I can't allow them to make unsafe choices. And so it's thinking about actually, I guess it's that capacity to consent issue, isn't it, that we would do so often in the work we do.
做父母并不容易。我想，你知道，我也是一个父母，但我也被抚养过。这有时是一种纠缠的概念，即父母无法真正看到他们的孩子有自己的愿望、需求和欲望。而且，你知道，如果我的孩子们长大后，他们不需要我在他们的生活中，但他们选择让我在他们的生活中，并且我能容忍他们做出不同的选择，我会认为我的工作做得很好。我能容忍他们做出，即使是现在，我能容忍他们做出不明智的选择。显然，我不能允许他们做出不安全的选择。所以这是在思考，实际上，我想这是那种同意能力的问题，不是吗？我们在工作中经常这样做。
So, yeah, I can allow you to make that choice, even though I don't agree with it, or it's not one I would make myself. And have that be okay that that person as being able to develop that autonomy. me. And I think it's when that hasn't been done in a robust way is when we kind of see problems in adulthood. I wonder, Nicole, if you've got like a little kind of case study example we could kind of latch onto, obviously it won't be a real client, but the thing about how this might have developed for somebody over time. It might be that, for example, a father or father figure is very volatile, very angry, quite unpredictable.
所以，是的，我可以允许你做出那个选择，即使我不同意，或者这不是我自己会做的选择。并且让那个人能够发展那种自主权。我。而且我认为当这种情况没有以稳健的方式完成时，我们就会在成年期看到问题。妮可，我想知道你是否有一个小案例研究例子，我们可以借鉴一下，显然它不会是一个真实的客户，但关于这可能如何随着时间的推移为某人发展。可能是，例如，父亲或父亲形象非常反复无常，非常愤怒，非常不可预测。
And what that does is that it causes fear in the mother, so that the mother likely becomes a bit of a sort of smaller person, a bit of a people-pleaser herself, someone who sort of shrinks into the background as much as possible, to keep safe. And that then happens to the children as well, right? So the children feel like if I'm small, if I'm unobtrusive, if I don't have needs, I'm easy to like. I'm easy to be around and no one pays attention to me.
而这导致了母亲的恐惧，所以母亲很可能变成了一个有点渺小的人，她自己也变成了一个讨好型人格者，一个为了保持安全而尽可能缩进背景的人。然后这种情况也会发生在孩子身上，对吧？所以孩子们觉得如果我很渺小，如果我不引人注目，如果我没有需求，我就很容易被喜欢。我很容易相处，没有人会注意我。
And actually that's what I want because I don't want to feel anyone's wrath. So that's often what I see in my practice is people who have come from those kind of backgrounds where one person's emotions really took up so much space in the house that there wasn't really for anyone else's. Yeah, and what we know is that the longer that continues, the more likely people are to to kind of have some of the presentation of kind of complex trauma where they might be using kind of self-soothing behaviours like alcohol, cigarettes, even that they're going to be more likely to have a higher body mass index, like a whole host of kind of physical health
而实际上这正是我想要的，因为我不想感受到任何人的愤怒。所以这就是我在我的执业中经常看到的，那些来自那种背景的人，其中一个人的情绪在家里占据了太多的空间，以至于没有真正为其他人的情绪留出空间。是的，我们知道这种情况持续的时间越长，人们就越有可能出现某种复杂创伤的表现，他们可能会使用酒精、香烟等自我抚慰行为，甚至他们更有可能拥有更高的身体质量指数，就像一大堆身体健康
complications as well. So the earlier we can kind of get in with that. And and give that person the chance for their body not to keep the score so that they can have a different outcome for themselves and ultimately for their friends and family and their own children if they have them, the better, really. Yeah, absolutely. And what I've learned through my own experience and I guess those of my clients
并发症一样。所以我们越早介入越好。并给那个人一个机会，让他们的身体不必“记录分数”，这样他们就可以为自己，并最终为他们的朋友、家人以及他们自己的孩子（如果他们有的话）带来不同的结果，这真的更好。是的，绝对是。通过我自己的经验，我想还有我客户的经验，我学到的是
is that this is always a work in progress. So once you become that kind of people pleaser, that compliance surrenderer, if we're talking in schema schema mode therapy it's you constantly have to think about your own capacity
这是一个正在进行的工作。所以一旦你成为那种讨好型人格者，那种顺从的投降者，如果我们用图式疗法模式来说的话，你必须不断地思考你自己的能力
and what you're saying yes to and whether you should have paused for a minute or how you can roll back on things where you did say yes when actually you couldn't necessarily do something so for me it is a constant work in progress and I think probably for most people It's something that they have to question themselves over throughout the rest of their lives, really.
以及你答应了什么，以及你是否应该暂停一分钟，或者你如何能在你确实答应了但实际上无法完成某些事情的情况下撤回。所以对我来说，这是一个不断进行的工作，我想对于大多数人来说，这是他们余生中必须不断质疑自己的事情，真的。
Yeah, and I would say I'm a recovering people pleaser and I'm a recovering dog poo bagger. I did do the test and I think I gave you my percentage of what I was. But, you know, it's very much been a work in progress over these last few years, I would say. If people are interested in taking the test, how can they do that? How long will it take them? So they can do the test on the website, which is dog poo bagtest.com, and it takes probably two minutes. So it's very quick, very easy. And, you know, this is not anything diagnostic.
是的，我会说我是一个正在康复的讨好型人格者，我是一个正在康复的“狗屎袋携带者”。我确实做了测试，我想我给了你我的百分比。但是，你知道，这在过去几年里确实是一个正在进行的工作。如果人们有兴趣参加测试，他们该怎么做？这需要多长时间？所以他们可以在网站上做测试，即 dogpoobagtest.com，大概需要两分钟。所以它非常快，非常容易。而且，你知道，这不是任何诊断。
It's just, it's kind of a bit of fun, also a bit serious. But hopefully through the toolkit, if you decide to purchase that, the toolkit will give you some ideas of how to recover, how to go into recovery from being a people pleaser. being a dog poo bag holder. Amazing because it's kind of that little bit of curiosity, isn't it? That maybe, oh, I hadn't quite realized what that was based on. And it's, yeah, really lovely to chat with you. If people want to follow you on socials, where's the best place for them to do that in a car? So it's at Dog poo bag test on Instagram.
这只是，它有点有趣，也有一点严肃。但希望通过工具包，如果你决定购买它，工具包会给你一些关于如何康复，如何从讨好型人格中康复的想法。成为一个狗屎袋携带者。太棒了，因为这是一种小小的好奇心，不是吗？也许，哦，我没完全意识到这是基于什么。而且，和你聊天真的很愉快。如果人们想在社交媒体上关注你，妮可，最好的地方是哪里？所以是 Instagram 上的 @Dogpoobagtest。
I can't say that there's a lot there, but you're welcome to have a look. Perfect. Thank you. I will make sure that all of these details, are tagged in the show notes, but sounds really, really interesting. And if anyone is enjoying this episode or recognising that they might be a dog poo bag holder, please do let us know in the comments. Thank you so much for all your time, Nicole. Thank you, Marianne.
我不能说那里有很多东西，但欢迎你来看看。完美。谢谢。我会确保所有这些详细信息都标记在节目说明中，但这听起来真的非常有趣。如果有人喜欢这一集，或者意识到他们可能是一个狗屎袋携带者，请务必在评论中告诉我们。非常感谢你的时间，妮可。谢谢，玛丽安。
You're welcome, lovely chatting with you. Thank you so much for watching. If you are not already following or subscribing to the show, please do so. It really does help us to reach a wider audience. Have you recognised yourself as a bit of a dog poo holder? If you've done the test, come and drop your percentage score into the chat. I would love to know what your score is. If you are curious about the journeys people take to becoming qualified psychologists,
不客气，和你聊天很愉快。非常感谢你的观看。如果你还没有关注或订阅这个节目，请务必这样做。这确实有助于我们接触到更广泛的受众。你是否意识到自己有点像个狗屎袋携带者？如果你做了测试，来把你的百分比分数发到聊天室里。我很想知道你的分数是多少。如果你对人们成为合格心理学家的旅程感到好奇，
I think you'll really love the book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective. If you'd like to grab your copy or check out other people's reviews from real readers, please do head to Amazon or there's a link in my link. link tree bio. And if you're a big fan of psychology actually as a podcast and you'd like to secure early access or some of the unique episodes called Inner Work, please do consider coming on board, which you can do for just a few pounds a month and you can join via Patreon where you get a seven day free trial, Apple podcast where you get a three three day trial, and then directly via captivate and YouTube too. If you've enjoyed this episode, I think you will really enjoy the episode
我想你会非常喜欢这本书，《临床心理学家集体》。如果你想获取你的副本或查看其他真实读者的评论，请前往亚马逊，或者我的 Linktree 个人简介中有一个链接。如果你是《心理学实际上》播客的忠实粉丝，并且想获得抢先体验或一些名为“内在工作”的独特剧集，请考虑加入，你每月只需几英镑就可以通过 Patreon 加入，在那里你可以获得七天免费试用，通过 Apple Podcast 可以获得三天试用，也可以直接通过 Captivate 和 YouTube 加入。如果你喜欢这一集，我想你会非常喜欢这一集
that I did with Dr. Rana on Let Them Theory and whether we're kind of interpreting it correctly all of the time. It's a brilliant episode. So that will be linked in the show notes or it's on screen as well for you. One of my favorite little moments in my working week is when I'm preparing to meet a new client and I click the smart import button in write-up. Before I moved over to write-up, I used to spend so much time manually inputting details, checking spellings, chasing information and worrying whether I'd copied things across correctly. Now clients complete their intake forms remotely in their own time on their own device, and with one click of that magic little smart import button, their information securely populates into the system ready for me. That means names, addresses, GP details, next-of-kin information, and more are already there before we even meet. It feels smoother and more professional for clients, but honestly, it also really reduces mental load for me as a clinician and business owner too.
我和拉纳博士做的关于“随他们去理论”以及我们是否一直在正确解读它的那一集。这是一集精彩的节目。所以它会链接在节目说明中，或者也在屏幕上为你显示。我工作周中最喜欢的小瞬间之一，就是准备见新客户时，点击 Write-Up 中的智能导入按钮。在转用 Write-Up 之前，我曾花费大量时间手动输入详细信息、检查拼写、追问信息，并担心是否复制正确。现在，客户可以在自己的时间、使用自己的设备远程完成入职表格，只需轻轻点击那个神奇的智能导入按钮，他们的信息就会安全地填充到系统中，准备就绪。这意味着姓名、地址、全科医生详细信息、近亲信息等，在我们见面之前就已经在那里了。这对客户来说感觉更顺畅、更专业，但老实说，这也确实减轻了我作为临床医生和企业主的心理负担。
And when you work in healthcare, having systems you can trust matters. WriteUp is the practice management platform built in the UK for UK practitioners. Have a look at writeup.com. That's WR-I-T-E-U-P-P.com. Use code Marianne 30 for 30 days free and 30% off your. your first six months and then you can see whether it's that smart import button or another of write-up's great features that makes you smile too There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当你从事医疗保健工作时，拥有值得信赖的系统非常重要。WriteUp 是专为英国从业者在英国打造的诊所管理平台。请访问 writeup.com。即 W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P.com。使用代码 Marianne 30 可获得 30 天免费试用，并享受前六个月 30% 的折扣，然后你就可以看看是那个智能导入按钮还是 Write-Up 的其他强大功能让你也感到开心。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。